This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We talk to a lot of architects on the show, but this week we're talking to an engineer. My name is Mark Blaschock, and I am a professional engineer in the state of Texas. He's like, really from Texas? Yes, yes.
这里是 99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们在节目中采访过很多建筑师，但本周我们要采访一位工程师。我叫马克·布拉斯霍克，我是德克萨斯州的注册职业工程师。他听起来真的很像德克萨斯人？是的，是的。
I'm a fourth or fifth generation Texan. I've forgotten which one. But I've been raised in other parts of the country too, so I can talk to talk because I have been raised in the East Coast, you know. We talked to Mark about one of the first projects that he ever worked on. That's producer Emmett Pisterald. He had just graduated from college at the University of Houston, and he'd gotten a job in Austin with the Texas Department of Transportation.
我是第四代或第五代德克萨斯人。我都记不清是第几代了。但我也在其他地方长大，所以我说起话来很地道，因为我是在东海岸长大的，你知道的。我们和马克聊了他最早参与的项目之一。那是制作人埃米特·皮斯特拉德。他刚从休斯顿大学毕业，在奥斯汀的德克萨斯州交通部找到了一份工作。
I was in my mid-twenties at the time, so 40 years ago. Actually, I like to say four decades, it sounds like less. I was assigned to a number of things, but I ended up on the Congress Avenue Bridge that is the reconstruction of the Congress Avenue Bridge. The Anne Richards Congress Avenue Bridge is just a simple concrete arch bridge that spans Lady Bird Lake in downtown Austin. The bridge was completed in 1910, but by the late 1970s it was in need of a tune-up. It was structurally deficient, and so it rebuilt, and more conventional, more modern, more
我当时二十五岁左右，那是 40 年年前的事了。其实，我喜欢说四十年，听起来短一些。我被分配负责很多事情，但我最终参与了国会大道桥的项目，也就是国会大道桥的重建工程。安·理查兹国会大道桥是一座简单的混凝土拱桥，跨越奥斯汀市中心的伯德夫人湖。该桥于 1910 年建成，但到 20 世纪 70 年代末，它已经需要进行修缮了。它的结构存在缺陷，因此需要重建，更常规、更现代、更
contemporary beams were put in called box beams. The box beams sit below the road surface, and they need to be spaced a certain distance apart. Mark and the other engineers decided that the gap should be somewhere between three quarters of an inch and an inch and a half. And the size of that gap didn't seem like a particularly meaningful decision until the bats moved in. Every year in the spring, Mexican-free-tailed bats migrate from Mexico to central Texas,
当代被称为箱形梁的梁被安装了上去。箱形梁位于路面下方，它们需要保持一定的间距。马克和其他工程师决定，这个间距应该在四分之三英寸到一英寸半之间。在蝙蝠搬进来之前，这个间距的大小似乎并不是一个特别有意义的决定。每年春天，墨西哥无尾蝠都会从墨西哥迁徙到德克萨斯州中部，
and they're looking for caves or old barns or some other protected spot where they can safely hang upside down during the day. And shortly after the bridge renovation, a bunch of bats came across the new design and were like, hey, this has got perfectly sized, cozy crevices now. It accidentally created this perfect environment for the bats to move into. And they did. In the years that followed the renovation,
它们在寻找洞穴、旧谷仓或其他受保护的地点，以便白天能在那里安全地倒挂着休息。桥梁翻新后不久，一群蝙蝠偶然发现了这个新设计，心想：嘿，这里现在有了完美尺寸的舒适缝隙。它无意中为蝙蝠创造了一个完美的栖息环境。它们确实搬进去了。在翻新后的几年里，
hundreds of thousands of free-tailed bats started roosting inside the bridge. And of thousands of free-tailed bats started roosting inside the bridge. And the people of Austin lost it. There was quite a bit of hysteria in Austin back then about bats and rabies. The local newspaper, the Austin American Statesman published headlines like, bats sink teeth into Austin. The New York Daily News went with mass fear in the air as bats invade Austin.
成千上万只无尾蝠开始在桥内筑巢。成千上万只无尾蝠开始在桥内筑巢。奥斯汀的人们彻底抓狂了。当时奥斯汀对蝙蝠和狂犬病有着相当程度的恐慌。当地报纸《奥斯汀美国政治家报》发表了诸如“蝙蝠咬入奥斯汀”之类的头条新闻。《纽约每日新闻》则使用了“随着蝙蝠入侵奥斯汀，恐惧在空中弥漫”的标题。
And as the colony continued to grow, so did the fear. Folks were starting to come up with plans to exterminate the bats, to get them out of the bridge because they were everybody knew that they were, uh, or dangerous in a threat to human health and safety. The bats had just moved into their new home and right away it looked like they were about to get evicted or even wiped out altogether. But someone was about to arrive in Austin to stick up for these bats, an advocate of sorts
随着蝙蝠群不断扩大，恐惧也在加剧。人们开始想出各种计划来消灭蝙蝠，把它们从桥上赶出去，因为大家都知道它们是……呃，对人类健康和安全的危险和威胁。蝙蝠刚刚搬进它们的新家，眼看着就要被驱逐甚至被彻底消灭了。但正当此时，有人即将抵达奥斯汀来为这些蝙蝠撑腰，算是一位拥护者吧，
and the court of public opinion. He was an ambitious young ecologist who was looking for a chance to show the world not only that bats weren't as scary and dangerous as they were cracked up to be, but that we could live harmoniously alongside them right in the middle of a city. Enter the batman. Hi, I'm Merlin Tuttle and I've studied bats for the last nearly 65 years. Merlin Tuttle is one of the world's most prominent bat scientists.
也是舆论法庭上的辩护人。他是一位雄心勃勃的年轻生态学家，他想借此机会向世界证明，蝙蝠并不像人们想象的那样可怕和危险，而且我们完全可以与它们在城市中心和谐共处。有请蝙蝠侠。嗨，我是梅林·塔特尔，在过去的近 65 年里我一直在研究蝙蝠。梅林·塔特尔是世界上最杰出的蝙蝠科学家之一。
And unlike a lot of people, he loves bats. He's been obsessed with them since he was a teenager growing up in Tennessee. I lived just a couple miles from a bat cave and became very fascinated with the bats. Maybe a little too fascinated. I got so excited about bats that I forgot to go to school sometimes. But he managed to get through high school in college and eventually made it to graduate school. During his PhD research, he used the share bat caves with Tennessee moon shiners. They even gave him his nickname.
与很多人不同，他热爱蝙蝠。他从田纳西州长大的青少年时期起就对蝙蝠着迷了。我住的地方离一个蝙蝠洞只有几英里，这让我对蝙蝠着迷不已。也许有点太着迷了。我对蝙蝠太兴奋了，有时甚至忘了去上学。但他还是顺利读完了高中和大学，并最终进入了研究生院。在攻读博士学位期间，他曾与田纳西州的私酒酿造者共享蝙蝠洞。他们甚至给他起了个绰号。
The moon shiners would actually yell across each other, the Batman's are coming. They always had lookouts to make sure it wasn't the revenues. Merlin finished up his doctorate, and in 1975, he took a job in Wisconsin as the curator of mammals at the Milwaukee Public Museum. But it was kind of a tough time to be a bat scientist. A public opinion poll had just shown that bats ranked just below rattlesnakes and cockroaches
私酒酿造者其实会大声冲彼此喊叫：“蝙蝠侠来了。”他们总是安排放哨的人，以确保来的不是税务官。梅林完成了博士学业，并在 1975 年接受了威斯康星州密尔沃基公共博物馆哺乳动物馆长的工作。但作为一名蝙蝠科学家，那是一个相当艰难的时期。一项民意调查刚刚显示，在公众心目中，蝙蝠的排名仅略高于响尾蛇和蟑螂。
on public opinion. Nearly everybody knew that most of not all bats were rabid and would attack you. Bats were seen as terrifying creatures of the night, little furry monsters that would suck your blood and get tangled in your hair. And Roland says he would regularly read articles in mainstream magazines about swarms of rabid bats attacking people. A lot of these stories bore no resemblance to reality. They were just complete fiction.
几乎所有人都知道，大多数（如果不是全部）蝙蝠都患有狂犬病并且会攻击你。蝙蝠被视为可怕的暗夜生物，会吸你的血并缠在你头发里的小毛茸茸的怪物。罗兰说，他经常在主流杂志上读到关于狂犬蝙蝠群攻击人类的文章。其中许多故事与现实毫无关系。它们完全是虚构的。
It is a fact that bats are involved in the majority of rabies cases in the United States, and that rabies is an extremely deadly disease, but they're only one or two rabies cases a year in the U.S. And it's not like those people were die bombed out of the blue by some bloodthirsty bat. In all likelihood, they tried to pick up a bat, and they got bitten in self-defense. If they hadn't handled the bat, they'd have been perfectly safe. Merlin insists that if we don't bother bats, they won't bother us.
事实是，在美国，蝙蝠确实参与了大多数狂犬病病例，而且狂犬病是一种极其致命的疾病，但美国每年只有一两起狂犬病病例。而且也不是说那些人无缘无故地被某种嗜血的蝙蝠从天而降地炸死。很有可能是他们试图去抓一只蝙蝠，结果为了自卫而被咬了。如果他们没有去抓蝙蝠，他们就会非常安全。梅林坚称，如果我们不去打扰蝙蝠，它们就不会打扰我们。
And I mean, why would we bother bats? Bats are amazing. They have social systems that are strikingly similar to those of higher primates. They share information. They form long-term friendships, and they even adopt orphans. They're really incredible. And they're also really important for humans. They pollinate plants like mangoes and bananas. And all those agave plants from which the entire tequila and miscal production comes are dependent on bats for
我的意思是，我们为什么要打扰蝙蝠？蝙蝠太神奇了。它们的社会系统与高级灵长类动物惊人地相似。它们分享信息。它们建立长期友谊，甚至收养孤儿。它们真的很不可思议。而且它们对人类也非常重要。它们为芒果和香蕉等植物传粉。所有用于生产整个龙舌兰酒和梅斯卡尔酒的龙舌兰植物，其传粉都依赖于蝙蝠。
pollination. Without bats you could lose a more than a billion dollar industry. bats also eat tons of bugs including a lot of agricultural pests. By some estimates, bats save us farmers billions of dollars every year in pest control. But in the 70s and 80s as Merlin traveled the world doing his research everywhere he went he saw that bats were in trouble. In that research I couldn't help but notice that bat populations were decline in alarming rates. Bats were losing habitat to logging and agriculture and being driven from their homes by cave explorers. And in some places, people were just slaughtering them. And as I saw that, I became more and more concerned at the rate at which
如果没有蝙蝠，你可能会失去一个价值超过十亿美元的产业。蝙蝠还吃掉大量的昆虫，包括许多农业害虫。据估计，蝙蝠每年为我们农民节省了数十亿美元的害虫防治费用。但在 20 世纪 70 和 80 年代，当梅林环游世界进行研究时，他无论走到哪里都发现蝙蝠陷入了困境。在研究过程中，我情不自禁地注意到蝙蝠种群正以惊人的速度下降。蝙蝠因伐木和农业而失去栖息地，并被洞穴探险者赶出家园。在某些地方，人们甚至在大肆屠杀它们。当我看到这些时，我越来越担心人们毫无必要地杀死这些动物的速度。因此，在某个时刻，梅林顿悟了。他可以花一辈子的时间研究蝙蝠，做伟大的科学。但如果他热爱的动物被其他人鄙视，这又有什么用呢？他决定离开学术界，投身于保护这些被误解的生物。许多聪明人认为这是一个愚蠢的主意。哦，我的同事甚至我最好的朋友都认为这很黑暗甚至疯狂。蝙蝠保护被视为一个无望的议题。甚至连世界上最大的传统保护组织，
people were killing these animals needlessly. And so at a certain point, Merlin had an epiphany. He could spend his whole life studying bats, doing great science. But what good would it do if the animals that he loved were despised by everybody else? He decided that he needed to get out of academia and devote himself to protecting these misunderstood creatures. Which a lot of smart people thought was a dumb idea. Oh, my colleagues and even my best friends thought it's dark or even mad. Back conservation was viewed as a hopeless issue. Even the world's biggest traditional conservation organizations,
也不想和蝙蝠沾边。它们被认为太绝望地不受欢迎，根本无法得到帮助。但梅林并没有放弃。1982 年，他在密尔沃基创办了一个名为“国际蝙蝠保护”的组织。他开始在全国巡回演讲，向任何愿意倾听的人宣讲蝙蝠福音，其中包括大卫·莱特曼。他花 了 20 年时间研究蝙蝠，觉得它们没有得到应有的尊重。
one, nothing to do with bats. They were just deemed far too hopelessly unpopular to be helped. But Merlin pressed on. In 1982, he launched an organization called Bat Conservation International based in Milwaukee. And he began touring the country, preaching the bat gospel to anyone who would listen, including David Letterman. He has spent 20 years studying bats and feels that they don't get the respect they rightfully
欢迎梅林·塔特尔博士。梅林尽力了，但当他开始掏出活蝙蝠时，你能听到观众在椅子上不安地蠕动。有时，感觉莱特曼并没有把梅林和他的蝙蝠当回事。你对那只吉娃娃做了什么？梅林面临着一场硬仗，但在 20 世纪 80 年代中期，一个重大机遇从天而降。我第一次听说这件事时，已经有几十万只了。梅林得到消息称，德克萨斯州奥斯汀的一座桥上搬来了一个巨大的无尾蝠群。
deserve. Please welcome Dr. Merlin Tuttle. Merlin did his best, but you can hear the audience squirming in their chairs when he starts pulling out live bats. And at times, it doesn't feel like Letterman is taking Merlin and his bats very seriously. What have you done to that Chihuahua? Merlin was facing an uphill battle, but in the mid-1980s, a major opportunity fell in his lap. First time I heard about it, it was hundreds of thousands already. Merlin got word that a giant colony of free-tailed bats
并引起了全城范围内的集体恐慌。我们可以给你寄一份当时的宣传海报，它真实地讲述了这个故事。描绘了每个人惊恐逃跑、蝙蝠从桥上飞出的场景。人们真的很害怕，他们签署请愿书要求消灭这些蝙蝠。我心里很清楚，如果我不采取行动，这将是我所有努力的终点。所以在那个时刻，梅林做出了一个将改变他的人生方向以及奥斯汀蝙蝠群命运的决定。
had moved into a bridge in Austin, Texas. And we're causing a collective city-wide freak out. We could send you a copy of a poster from the time that really tells the story. Depicts everybody fleeing in terror and the bats coming out of the bridge. People were really frightened and they were sign petitions to have the bats eradicated. And I knew perfectly well that that was going to be the end of my efforts if I didn't do something about it. And so in that moment Merlin made a decision that would
他决定收拾行囊搬到德克萨斯州。奥斯汀将成为国际蝙蝠保护组织的新家，也将成为梅林·塔特尔代表蝙蝠发动公关战的中心。德克萨斯州奥斯汀最美的景色之一就是黄昏前的国会街大桥。你可能最不想看到的场景是，桥下有七十五万只蝙蝠在夜幕降临之际倾巢而出。
change the direction of his life and the fate of the Austin colony. He decided to pack up his things and move to Texas. Austin would be the new home of bat conservation international and ground zero in Merlin Tuttle's public relations war on behalf of bats. One of the prettiest sites in Austin, Texas is the Congress Street Bridge just before dusk. What you would probably rather not see is underneath the bridge, three-quarters of a million bats heading out for the night.
这段新闻广播来自 80 年代末，也就是梅林被发现后不久。对我们大多数人来说，一提到蝙蝠，脑海中就会浮现出疾病和厌恶的概念。但据总部设在奥斯汀的国际蝙蝠保护组织称，这种看法是错误的。梅林·塔特尔和他的团队声称，几个世纪以来，蝙蝠一直饱受恶名。它们被严重低估了研究，严重低估了价值，并受到了过度的迫害。但起初，梅林的亲蝙蝠信息在奥斯汀并没有得到太好的反响。杂志《德克萨斯月刊》授予梅林他们臭名昭著的“笨拙领航奖”，这是一个半开玩笑的荣誉，
This newscast is from the late 80s, just after Merlin was found. For most of us, the mere thought of a bat conjures up notions of disease and disgust. But that's wrong, according to Austin-based bad conservation international. Merlin Tuttle and his staff claimed bats have been getting a bad rap for centuries. They're vastly understudied, vastly underappreciated and overly persecuted. But at first, Merlin's pro-bat message didn't go over too well in Austin. The magazine Texas Monthly gave Merlin their infamous Bums Steer Award, a tongue-and-cheek
通常授予腐败政客和其他可疑人物。平心而论，当时拯救蝙蝠的想法确实显得非常可疑。你知道蝙蝠，如你所知，一直名声不好。这是琳达·摩尔，梅林搬到奥斯汀后雇用最早的人之一，也是他最早的“蝙蝠战队”皈依者之一。琳达应聘了一家“自然保护组织”的簿记工作广告。我对蝙蝠一无所知，因为他在广告中提到了这一点。但梅林没花多长时间就把她拉入了伙。我的意思是，关于蝙蝠的第一句话就把我迷住了，你知道的，我简直着迷了，
honor, typically reserved for corrupt politicians and other dubious figures. And to be fair, at the time, the idea of saving bats did seem highly dubious. You know bats, as you know, have had a bad wrap. This is Linda Moore, one of the first people Marlon hired after moving to Austin, and one of his very first converts to team bat. Linda responded to an ad for a bookkeeping job at a, quote, conservation organization. I didn't know what thing about bats because he had mentioned that in the ad. But it really didn't take Marlon very long to get her on board. I mean, he had me at the first sentence about bats, you know, and I was just mesmerized
他解释说，你知道，该组织的部分使命是消除这些神话并教育人们，我想，好吧，我全力支持这一点。于是她开始为该组织记账。琳达说，尽管有所有不利因素、负面宣传、虚假谣言和对狂犬病的恐惧，梅林开始对其他人产生了他对她产生过的那种影响。起初，人们不断惊恐地给办公室打电话。你知道，人们很害怕，他们会打电话，在电话里尖叫，
and he explained, you know, part of the mission of the organization was to dispel those myths and educate people, I thought, well, I'm all for that. So she started keeping the books for the organization. And Linda says that despite everything working against him, the negative publicity, the false rumors, the fear of rabies, Merlin began having the same effect on other people that he'd had on her. At first, people were constantly calling the office terrified. You know, people were afraid and they would call and they wouldn't scream on the phone
你知道，正如你们所有人能想象的那样，各种各样的事情。人们会说：“哦，我去看那些蝙蝠了，因为那天晚上它们上了新闻。而且，你知道，其中有一只，我想我被它撒尿了。你觉得我会得狂犬病吗？”琳达说，梅林总是会平静地劝导这些人。梅林有一种说话的方式，到对话结束时，他们会想知道如何才能，你知道的，拯救这些蝙蝠。
and, you know, all kinds of things as you can all imagine. People were like, Oh, I went out to see those bats because they were on the news the other night. And, you know, one of those, I think I got peed on. Do you think I have rabies? Linda says that Merlin would always calmly talk these people down. Merlin had such a way of talking to them that by the end of the conversation, they were wanting to know how they could, you know, kind of save these bats.
我为这个故事采访过的每个人都提到梅林几乎超自然的耐心。他没有向任何人长篇大论地说他们的恐惧是如何落后或错位的。他只是倾听，然后解释蝙蝠有多么重要。是的，我成功的关键在于我不是那种多愁善感、认为动物比人类拥有更多权利的动物爱好者。我所有保护工作的基础是：这对你有好处。我所有保护工作的基础是：这对你有好处。如果你投桃报李，这些动物就会离你远远的。一旦你这样做了，你将从中获得巨大的好处。梅林的主要论点是，蝙蝠通过提供免费的害虫防治使德克萨斯人受益。他估计，
Everyone that I spoke with for this story mentioned Merlin's almost preter natural patience. He didn't lecture anyone about how their fears were backwards or misplaced. He just listened and then explained how important bats were. Yes, a key to my success has been that I'm not a person who's a bleeding heart animal lover who just thinks that animals have more rights than humans. The basis of all my conservation work has been this is what's good for you. all my conservation work has been, this is what's good for you. These animals will leave you alone if you return the favor. And once you do that, you'll benefit greatly from them. Merlin's main argument was that bats were benefiting Texans by providing free pest control. He estimated
在任何给定的夏夜，国会大道桥的蝙蝠会吃掉 20,000 磅的昆虫。其中许多是农业害虫，位于镇外的农田里。凭借他冷静、对事实本身的风格，梅林赢得了农民、老师和公共卫生官员的支持。然后媒体报道开始转变。《政治家报》发表文章向读者保证，只要人们不触摸任何蝙蝠，桥上的蝙蝠群就是绝对安全的。《国家地理》甚至还发表了一篇文章来庆祝奥斯汀的蝙蝠。
that on any given summer night, the Congress Avenue bats were eating 20,000 pounds of insects. Many of them, agricultural pests, and the farmland outside of town. With his calm, matter-of-fact style, Merlin won over farmers and teachers and public health officials. And then the media coverage started to shift. The statesmen published article's reassuring readers that the bridge colony was perfectly safe as long as people didn't touch any bats. There was even an article celebrating Austin's bats in National Geographic.
那篇文章实际上刊登了梅林自己拍的照片。他之所以学会摄影，是因为他厌倦了看到那些为了让蝙蝠看起来具有威胁性而拍摄的照片。正面拍摄时，蝙蝠会张大嘴巴发出回声定位脉冲，看起来像是在攻击，但我会拍一个四分之三角度的照片，让它看起来好像在微笑，这会对公众的perception产生巨大的改变。在我的照片里，蝙蝠都在微笑，和其他任何动物一样可爱。
And that article actually featured pictures that Merlin had taken himself. He had picked up photography because he was tired of seeing photos that had been shot to make the bats look menacing. The straight-on shots, the bat has these mouth wide open sending out echolocation pulses and he can look like he's attacking, but I'll take a three-quarter angle shot where he actually looks like he may be smiling and it makes a huge difference to public perception. And my pictures, the bats are all smiling and just as cute as any other animal.
梅林坚信人们害怕自己不了解的事物。所以他希望确保奥斯汀的人们有机会近距离了解真正的蝙蝠。实际上是一只特别的蝙蝠。一只非常可爱的被称为狐蝠的蝙蝠，是从肯尼亚之行中带回来的。它的名字叫祖里。如果你见过那种眼睛超级大、看起来像小狗的蝙蝠，也许它正在 YouTube 视频里大口嚼着香蕉，是的，祖里就是其中之一。他是我们的媒体明星。他是，梅林会带着他去任何地方，你知道的，他上过电视节目和
Merlin was convinced that people fear things they don't know. So we wanted to make sure people in Austin got the chance to know real bats up close. One bat in particular, actually. A very cute bat called a flying fox that was brought back from a trip to Kenya. Its name was Erie. If you've ever seen one of those really big-eyed bats that looks like a puppy, maybe it was munching on a banana and a YouTube video, yeah, Zuri was one of those. He was our media star. He was, Merlin would take him everywhere, you know, he was on television programs and
其他所有节目。我必须称赞祖里，因为他太可爱了。你带着这个小家伙到处去演讲展示，你就赢得了人们的心。这是祖里。他在斯瓦希里语中的名字是“美丽”。在这个片段中，国际蝙蝠保护组织的一名工作人员正在小学教室里向小学生展示祖里。
everything else. And I must give Zuri credit because he was just adorable. And you take that guy around and show him at talks and everything and you've won people over. This is Zuri. And his name in Swahili means beautiful. In this clip, someone from Bat Conservation International is holding Zuri in front of a classroom of elementary school children.
孩子们起初看起来很犹豫。蝙蝠咬人疼吗？嗯，有些蝙蝠有锋利的牙齿，因为它们需要锋利的牙齿。有人看到它试图咬人吗？没有，它非常温和。这就是大多数蝙蝠天性中的样子。它们用什么喂养它们的宝宝？血吗？不，它们用奶喂养宝宝。随着时间的推移，奥斯汀的小学生们
The kids initially seem pretty hesitant. Do bats bite hard? Well, some bats have sharp teeth because they need sharp teeth. Has anyone seen him try and bite? No, he's very gentle. And this is the way most bats are naturally. What do they feed their babies? And blood? No, they feed their babies milk. Over time the school children of Austin
接受了这一切。他们甚至开始组建小型的蝙蝠保护俱乐部，渐渐地，奥斯汀对蝙蝠的态度从恐惧转变为接受，最后甚至变成了热情。人们意识到他们一直在忽视每晚都在上演的自然奇观。一百万只蝙蝠在德克萨斯夏日落日的背景下飞走。它们蜂拥而出，在云层中交织成波浪，看起来非常壮观。这是埃德·克劳威尔。
bought in. They even started forming little bat conservation clubs and little by little Austin's relationship to its bats shifted from fear to acceptance and eventually even to enthusiasm. People realized that they had been ignoring this natural spectacle that was playing out every night. A million bats flying off against the backdrop of a Texas summer sunset. They stream out and kind of bingle with the clouds and these waves and it's a pretty thing to watch. This is Ed Crowell.
他曾担任《奥斯汀美国政治家报》多年的记者。报社办公室就在桥旁边，埃德说，在某个时候，一些勇敢的动物爱好者开始在黄昏时分出现观看蝙蝠出巢。其他人也加入进来，到了 90 年代，每天晚上桥上都挤满了人。每年的六到八个月里，只要蝙蝠在这里的每个傍晚，人们就会在人行道的两侧排成四五排深来观看蝙蝠。哇。这座城市开始接受它。哇。
He was a reporter for the Austin American Statesman for many years. The paper's offices are right next to the bridge, and Ed says that at a certain point a few brave animal lovers started showing up at dusk to watch the bats emerge. Others joined in and by the 90s there was a crowd on the bridge every night. Every evening for six, eight months of the year that the bats were here, they just, you know, people would just stand four or five deep on both sides of the sidewalk to see the bats. Wow. In the city started to embrace it. Wow.
这座城市开始接受它。各种企业纷纷涌现，提供日落蝙蝠游船服务。在某个时候，《政治家报》决定在他们的办公室旁边建造一个蝙蝠观赏区。人们开始从外地预订酒店房间来看蝙蝠。这是他们在奥斯汀可以做的事情之一。于是这座城市和当时的市长就出资，这几乎就像是一个旅游景点。克服重重困难，梅林·塔特尔成功地
In the city started to embrace it. Businesses cropped up offering sunset back cruises. At a certain point the newspaper of the statesmen decided to build a bat viewing area next to their office. People started booking hotel rooms from out of town to come see the bats. It's one of the things they could do in Austin. And so then the city and the mayor at the time just paid, this is almost like a tourist attraction. Against all odds, Merlin Tuttle had successfully
重新塑造了这座城市蝙蝠的形象。1990 年，也就是梅林搬到该镇四年后，市长宣布奥斯汀为美国的蝙蝠之都。马克·布拉斯霍克，美国的蝙蝠之都。马克·布拉斯霍克，这座桥的工程师，并不是故意让这一切发生的。但他饶有兴致地看着他这个非常实用的基础设施成为世界上最大的城市蝙蝠群的家园，也成为奥斯汀最大的景点之一。
rebranded the city's bats. In 1990, four years after Merlin moved to town, the mayor declared Austin the bat capital of America. Mark Blaschock, the Bat Capital of America. Mark Blaschock, the engineer who built the bridge, didn't mean for any of this to happen. But he watched with interest as his very practical piece of infrastructure became home to the world's largest urban bat colony, and one of Austin's biggest attractions.
马克将这座城市最终接受蝙蝠的大部分功劳归于梅林。确实需要像梅林·塔特尔这样具有独特非对抗性风格的人，才能开始扭转人们对蝙蝠的看法。他是那种能让你想要去帮忙的人。在接下来的几年里，马克开始思考他可以如何帮助蝙蝠。他想知道德克萨斯州的所有其他桥梁情况如何。那里一定还有更多的蝙蝠群。
Mark gives Merlin a lot of the credit for the way the city eventually embraced its bats. It really took somebody like Merlin Tuttle with his unique style of non-confrontationalism to be able to start to change the tide on how people felt about bats. He's the type of person that makes you want to help. In the years that followed, Mark started thinking about ways that he could help the bats. He wondered what about all the other bridges in Texas. There must be more bat colonies out there.
因此，在另一位名为布赖恩·基利的蝙蝠科学家和德克萨斯州资金的帮助下，马克开始踏上寻找蝙蝠桥梁的乡间小路。我们在德克萨斯州有许多桥梁都有蝙蝠群。在某些情况下，有相当大的群落，那个就是，你知道的，那是标志性的。那是每个人都会想到的。但马克和布赖恩发现，德克萨斯州至少有 1100 万只蝙蝠依靠桥梁和涵洞
And so with the help of another bat scientist named Brian Keely and funding from the state of Texas, Mark started traveling the back roads in search of bat bridges. We have a number of bridges in Texas that have bat colonies. In some cases, there are fairly large congresses, the one that is the, you know, that's the hallmark. That's the one that everybody thinks of. But Mark and Brian found that at least 11 million bats in Texas were relying on bridges and culverts
作为日间庇护所。然后他们将这项研究扩大到全国范围，发现桥梁和涵洞为全国各地的蝙蝠提供了重要的栖息地。因此，他们为德克萨斯州交通部制定了指南，开始有意设计桥梁以吸引蝙蝠。
for daytime shelter. And then they expanded that study nationally and figured out that bridges and culverts for daytime shelter. And then they expanded that study nationally and figured out that bridges and culverts were providing important habitat for bats across the country. And so they came up with guidelines for the Texas Department of Transportation to start intentionally designing bridges to attract bats.
现在，如果他们在蝙蝠群有意义的地方建造桥梁，他们会像在国会大道那样，将箱形梁的间距保持在四分之三英寸到一英寸半之间，正如蝙蝠所喜欢的那样。如果它们找到了并且会这样做，并在其中建立了一个蝙蝠群，它们就会为我们做一件好事。相反，如果他们在某个地方建造桥梁，
Now, if they're building a bridge in a place where a bat colony makes sense, they will space the box beams the way they did at Congress Avenue between three quarters of an inch and an inch and a half apart, just how the baths like it. If they find it and they will and they get a colony going in it, they'll do us a good service. And conversely, if they're building a bridge in a place where
蝙蝠和人类可能会靠得太近，我们会专门将那两根箱形梁之间的缝隙设计得大于两英寸。你猜怎么着？我们将不会招来任何蝙蝠。马克最终的大部分职业生涯都致力于让基础设施对蝙蝠更友好。不久前，他因一项涵洞设计获得了联邦公路管理局的奖项。他说，联邦官员简直不敢相信，一群工程师和生物学家
baths and humans might get a little too close to one another, we specifically will have the crevice between those two boxbeams will specifically have that be greater than two inches. Guess what? We're not going to get any bats. Mark ended up spending much of his career working to make infrastructure more bat friendly. A while back, he won an award from the Federal Highway Administration for a covert design. And he says that the feds couldn't believe that a bunch of engineers and biologists
竟然会自愿合作完成这个项目。生物学家和工程师通常不被视为天然的合作者。在这个问题上，我们几乎可以被视为处于光谱的两端。工程师站在人类一边，生物学家站在野生动物一边。
had worked together on the project voluntarily. Biologists and engineers are not seen as natural collaborators. We're almost, we could be perceived on opposite sides of a spectrum with regard to this issue. Engineers on the side of people, biologists on the side of wildlife.
但马克的全部观点是：如果我们都在同一个团队里会怎么样？这两者是可以结合在一起的。它不必仅仅关乎混凝土、钢材、先进材料、应力、应变、耐久性和成本。我们还可以做其他对自然环境产生积极或消极影响的事情。微调几根箱形梁之间的缝隙宽度可能看起来不是什么大事。但从某种意义上说，马克正在改变工程师的定义。他说，建筑环境和自然环境并不需要水火不容。
But Mark's whole thing was like, what if we're all on the same team here? The two things can go together. It doesn't have to just be about concrete and steel and advanced materials and stress and strain and durability and cost. There can be other things that we do that affect positively or negatively the natural environment. Very in the width of the gaps between a few box beams might not seem like an important act. But in a way, Mark is shifting what it means to be an engineer. He's saying the built environment and the natural environment don't need to be at odds with one another.
可能没有人会错过的最好例子之一就是新国会大桥，我们是如何共同努力，将它从一个充满恐惧和厌恶的地方（如果你愿意的话）变成奥斯汀文化中不可或缺的一部分。夏天的每个夜晚，人们都在国会大道桥上排起长队。伯德夫人湖上挤满了皮划艇、独木舟和浮筒船，就在日落时分，150 万只蝙蝠开始从桥下倾巢而出，人群发出惊叹声。它们向下游飞去，开始它们的夜间盛宴，在一个小时左右的时间里，
And probably one of the best examples that nobody could miss is the Congress of the New Bridge, how we all work together to take it from a place of fear and loathing, if you will, to a place that's definitely an entrenched part of the Austin culture. Every night in the summer, people line up on the Congress Avenue bridge. Lady Bird Lake is filled with kayaks and canoes and pontoon boats, and then right at sundown 1.5 million bats start to trickle out of the bridge as the crowd ooze and oz. They fly off downstream to begin their nightly feast, and over the course of an hour or Look at that. Look at your eyes. Look at your eyes. Yeah, there you go. That's cool. They fly off downstream to begin their nightly feast, and over the course of an hour or so,
看那个。看你的眼睛。看你的眼睛。对，就这样。太酷了。它们向下游飞去，开始它们的夜间盛宴，在一个小时左右的时间里，
the flow of bats increases until they form this sneaking river in the sky that stretches for what seems like miles. Merlin Tuttle has traveled the world to see bats in incredible wild places, but he never gets tired of a good night at the bridge. I mean, it's just truly spectacular. It's one of these spectacular natural events in the world. And it's right in the middle of a city. Special thanks to Teresa Nicta, who helped coordinate our interview with Merlin. Also to know that Merlin no longer works for Bat Conservation International,
蝙蝠的涌流不断增加，直到它们在天空中形成这条绵延数英里似乎没有尽头的蜿蜒河流。梅林·塔特尔曾游历世界各地，在令人惊叹的野外地方观赏蝙蝠，但他从未对在桥上度过美好的夜晚感到厌倦。我的意思是，这真是太壮观了。这是世界上最壮观的自然事件之一。而且它就位于城市正中央。特别感谢特蕾莎·尼克塔，她协助协调了我们对梅林的采访。还要注意的是，梅林不再为国际蝙蝠保护组织工作了，
the organization that he founded back in the 1980s. He stepped down from his role there a few years back and founded another organization, Merlin Tuttle's Bat Conservation. Both these great organizations are doing important work, including taking on one of the biggest threats facing bats today, White Nose Syndrome. White Nose is a disease that has killed so many bats across North America in recent years. It is a massive issue, and we couldn't get into it for this story, but we'll have links to where you can read more about it on our website, notinipi.org. And now for something completely different. Regularly with the help of the Autodesk Foundation, we like to cover impact design.
这个组织是他在 20 世纪 80 年代创立的。几年前他辞去了那里的职务，并创立了另一个组织——梅林·塔特尔蝙蝠保护协会。这两个伟大的组织都在做着重要的工作，包括应对当下面临的最大威胁之一：白鼻综合征。白鼻病是一种近年来导致北美无数蝙蝠死亡的疾病。这是一个巨大的问题，我们无法在这个故事中深入探讨，但我们会在我们的网站 notinipi.org 上提供链接，供您阅读更多相关信息。现在，我们来聊点完全不同的。在欧特克基金会的支持下，我们定期喜欢报道影响力设计。
That's designed that's focused on making the world a better place. And to that end, I'm talking with Simon Dobel, the CEO of Solar Buddy, a charity based in Australia that designs and gives away solar powered devices to children who are living with extreme energy poverty, which affects their ability to study and do things after the sunsets in a toxic free environment. To put it another way, Solar Buddy gives kids solar powered light so they don't have to burn
也就是专注于让世界变得更美好的设计。为此，我正在与 Solar Buddy 的首席执行官西蒙·多贝尔交谈，这是一个总部位于澳大利亚的慈善机构，他们设计太阳能设备并将其赠送给生活在极端能源贫困中的儿童，这种贫困影响了他们在太阳落山后在无毒环境中学习和做事情的能力。换句话说，Solar Buddy 为孩子们提供太阳能灯，这样他们就不必燃烧
kerosene to read after dark. When I talked to Simon last week, I started by asking him to describe energy poverty to me because I'd never really heard the term before. Yeah, that's a very common statement that I received. I got into energy poverty after reading a time magazine article in 2011 that described energy energy poverty as the worst form of poverty and it literally just stopped me in my tracks because I was back then I was a lot like you. I was familiar with multiple forms of poverty but energy poverty, what's this? I didn't know anything about it. The article stated that 1.4 billion people, about one in five people on the planet, live in extreme energy poverty, which essentially is there's no form of electricity. So they're still burning basic fire, oil or charcoal to cook,
煤油在天黑后阅读。上周我和西蒙交谈时，我首先请他向我描述能源贫困，因为我以前从未真正听过这个词。是的，这是我收到的非常常见的说法。我在 2011 年读到一篇《时代》杂志文章后开始关注能源贫困，该文章将能源贫困描述为最糟糕的贫困形式，这简直让我停下了脚步，因为那时我跟你很像。我对多种形式的贫困都很熟悉，但能源贫困是什么？我对此一无所知。文章指出，有 14 亿人，大约占地球上五分之一的人口，生活在极端能源贫困中，这基本上意味着没有任何形式的电力。所以他们仍然燃烧基础的木柴、石油或木炭来做饭，
they're burning, caressing oil and lanterns to see for light and very, very primitive toxic forms of fuel to see and cook and eat their homes. Since 2011, that number of 1.4 billion has come down to about 850 million. So there's been huge strides in that problem, but there's still a huge issue, 850 million people. And it's predominantly across sub-Sahara Africa, remote India, and a succumbent of India in Southeast Asia, where people are literally walking for kilometers a day to get firewere or paying premium prices for really toxic fuels like kerosene. Just to be able to function it, it's very simple. That's what we do. Energy poverty in extreme cases. There is energy poverty in inner city, New York, in inner city Los Angeles, and inner city Sydney where I am today, because there's people that have very low incomes in their energy bill was one of the first that goes from their
他们燃烧煤油和灯笼来照明，并使用非常非常原始的有毒燃料在他们的家中照明、做饭和吃饭。自 2011 年以来，14 亿这个数字已经下降到大约 8.5 亿。因此，这个问题取得了巨大的进展，但它仍然是一个巨大的问题，8.5 亿人。它主要分布在撒哈拉以南非洲、印度偏远地区以及东南亚的印度附属地区，那里的人们实际上每天要步行数公里去寻找木柴，或者支付极高的价格购买像煤油这样真正有毒的燃料。仅仅为了能够运转，这就非常简单。这就是我们所做的。极端情况下的能源贫困。纽约市中心、洛杉矶市中心以及我今天所在的悉尼市中心都存在能源贫困，因为那里有人收入非常低，他们的能源账单是他们优先考虑列表中最先被剔除的之一。因此世界各地都存在能源贫困，但这是我们所从事的极端能源贫困。是什么导致从 14 亿减少到 8.5 亿？仅仅是基础设施，还是像你们所做的那样的人工干预？干预，百分之百是干预，太阳能电池板的成本和性能以及制造非常小、高性能且极具成本效益的产品的能力。那是最大的飞跃。没错。那 14 亿人并不仅仅是因为有了输送电力的电线送到他们家里，
priority list. So there's energy probably all across the world, but that's the one that we work in as an extreme energy poverty. What accounts for the reduction from 1.4 billion to 800 million. Was it just infrastructure or was it interventions like the things that you do? Interventions, 100% interventions, the cost in performance of solar panels and the ability to make very small, very high performing and very cost effective. That was the biggest leap. Right. Those 1.4 billion are no more likely to have a wire delivering electricity to their house,
而是他们更有可能拥有一个高效的小型太阳能电池板，能够完成他们需要的很多事情。完全正确。完全正确。是的。你能向人们描述一下 Solar Buddy 的小工具吗？照片里的那个东西是什么？我们在我们工作的任何领域都非常具体。
but they're much more likely to have an efficient small solar panel that does a lot of things they need to do. Exactly. Exactly right. Yeah. Can you describe the solar body gadgets to people? What is the object of the baking picture? We're very specific in any area that we work in.
那就是儿童。我们非常清楚，孩子们在傍晚时分围着煤油灯读书和做作业时会遭受极大的痛苦。这是他们拥有的基本照明来源。我们都看过拉各斯和尼日利亚的大学生坐在路灯下学习的图片，因为他们家里没有电。拉各斯和尼日利亚的大学生，坐在路灯下学习，
And that's children. We know very clearly that children suffer terribly by reading and doing their homework of an evening around a carousine lantern. And that's the basic source of the lighting that they have. We've all seen the images of the University students in Lagos and Nigeria sitting underneath the street lies studying because they have no power in their homes. the University students in Lagos and Nigeria, sit and underneath the street lights studying
因为他们家里没有电。嗯，Solar Buddy 为孩子们提供学习用灯，让他们在村庄里感到安全。这是我们工作的主要重点。我们通过一个名为 Junior Buddy Light 的小型 Solar Buddy 灯来实现这一点，这是一个小型的个人灯，由世界各地的其他儿童捐赠给孩子们。我们知道，孩子们一旦收到我们的灯，他们的学习时间会比以前延长多达 78%，这对他们的教育成果产生了巨大的影响。这就是我们工作的核心。然而，我们非常清楚还有一个更大的问题，高中生有更大的需求和不同的环境需要满足。所以我们有一个名为 Student Buddy 的产品，这是一个更技术性、更强大的太阳能产品、太阳能照明系统，还可以为手机充电。我们将这些系统捐赠给高中的青少年学生，让他们留在学校，并为他们现在正在使用的那些设备供电。
because they have no power in their homes. Well, solar body provides lights for children to study with and to feel safe in their villages. That's the primary focus of what we do. And we do that through a little solar body light, which we call the junior body light, which is a little personal light that children have donated to them
即使他们在偏远的埃塞俄比亚或马达加斯加山区，青少年仍然拥有非常基础的手机。然而，他们没有能力给它们充电。所以他们请假几天，步行很长的时间和距离去当地村庄或偏远村庄给他们昂贵的发电机充电。所以我们提供系统，以便学生实际上可以在家里给自己的手机充电，这节省了他们的时间并让他们继续学习。你有点像在你的论文陈述中提到了这一点，它有点像格林顿（Greenton）以及你正在做的事情，
by other children around the world. And we know that children, once they receive one of our lights, they study enough to 78% longer than what they were previously, which has a huge impact on their educational outcomes. That's the essence of what we do. However, we're very aware that there's a bigger problem, and high school students have greater needs and different circumstances to fulfill. So we have a product called Student Buddy which is a more technical, more powerful solar product, solar lighting system that also charges mobile phones. And we donate these systems to teenage students in high school, to keep them in school, and to power those devices that they are now using.
在环境中避免有毒化学物质。你能多描述一下这种状况吗，在一个小地方燃烧炉子或燃煤炉或燃煤灯意味着什么。接下来，这是你们试图避免的情况吗？对于许多没有经历过的人来说，这真的很难理解。
Even if they're in remote Ethiopia or in Mount Magasca, teenage children still have very basic mobile phones. However, they have no ability to charge them. So they take days off school and walk a tremendous amount of time, distance to go to a local village or remote village to power their funded high cost, create these generators. So we're providing systems so the students can actually charge their own phones at home, which saves them time and keeps them studying. You mentioned this in sort of like your thesis statement and it's sort of like in Greenton and what you're doing,
我环游世界，我在能源贫困领域工作了很多年，我去过撒哈拉以南非洲的各个社区，我们经常在棚屋和小社区里工作，但那里至少根本没有窗户，也没有烟囱。所以想象一下燃烧高度有毒的煤油灯，它会释放黑碳，这是最糟糕的碳形态之一。想象一下每周七天、每天 24 小时燃烧它，因为没有自然光进来，所以你需要这种光。几乎每次我走进其中一些棚屋时，我说一分钟，最多两分钟，我的鼻子就开始流涕。我的眼睛流泪，我在咳嗽。喉咙里的刺痛感让人无法忍受，我必须
the avoidance of toxic chemicals in an environment. Could you describe that a little bit more about what the condition, what it means to have a, what burning stove in a small location or a coal burning stove or a carousine burning lamp. Next, what is the situation that you're trying to avoid? This isn't really hard for so many people that haven't experienced it to comprehend.
走到外面去呼吸新鲜空气。我已经这样做了很多很多年，即使过了这么长时间，我还是不习惯。然而对于我们支持的家庭和儿童来说，坐在那里好几个小时对他们来说是完全正常的。这就是问题所在，他们每天晚上和白天吸入的有毒烟雾。他们甚至没有注意到。它没有，它没有，因为他们看不见。它不会在手臂上造成烧伤或类似的东西。没有这种观念认为这实际上是
I've traveled the world, I've worked in energy poverty for many years now, and I go to communities across Sub-Sahara Africa, and so often we work in Huts and little communities, but at least have no windows at all, they have no chimneys. So imagine burning of highly toxic carotene lanterns, it gives up black carbon, which is one of the worst forms of carbon. Imagine burning that 24 hours a day, seven days a week, because there's no natural light coming in, so you need this light. And almost every time I go into some of these hearts, I'm talking one minute, maybe two minute max before my nose is streaming. My eyes are streaming, I'm coughing. The tickle on your throat is unbearable and I have
非常非常对他们有害的。所以我们的工作是提高对这一点的认识，以及儿童吸入的烟雾每年杀死的儿童人数超过艾滋病和疟疾的总和，每年有 260 万儿童仅死于他们通过生活吸入的烟雾，不是通过做任何奢侈的事情，纯粹是通过生活并在他们的家中而死，这真的是可怕的，直到你亲自体验过，你才无法理解烟雾对你的影响有多快，这真的很重要。我的意思是，关于它的事情之一是我从你那里得到的，也许如果我得到了错误的印象，请告诉我，这似乎是可行的。
to get outside and I have to take a fresh air. And I've been doing this for many, many years and even after so long, I'm still not used to it. Yet the families and the children that we support, it's completely normal for them to just sit there for hours on end. And this is the problem that the toxic fumes that they're breathing in on a daily basis and a nightly basis. They don't even notice it. It doesn't, it doesn't, because they can't see it. It doesn't create burns on their arms or or anything like that. There isn't this notion that it's actually really,
走到外面去呼吸新鲜空气。我做这件事已经很多很多年了，即使过了这么久，我还是很不习惯。然而，对于我们支持的家庭和孩子们来说，他们连续几个小时坐在那里是再正常不过的事了。问题在于，他们每天晚上都在吸入有毒烟雾。他们甚至都没有注意到。这并没有，也没有，因为他们看不见。它不会在他们的胳膊上造成烧伤或类似的东西。人们并没有这种概念，觉得这其实真的，
really bad for them. And then so our job is to raise awareness about that and the fact that the fumes that children are breathing in killed more children than AIDS and malaria combined every year by 2.6 million children died just from the fumes that they're breathing it just by living, not by doing anything extravagant purely by living and being in their homes is truly awful and until you actually experience it first hand you can't comprehend how quickly the fumes affect you and that's really important. I mean, one of the things about it that is I'm getting from you and maybe if I'm getting the wrong impression, let me know that it seems doable.
对他们非常不好。所以我们的工作就是提高人们对此的认识，事实上，每年有 260 万儿童死于孩子们吸入的烟雾，这一数字超过了艾滋病和疟疾致死人数的总和。仅仅是因为他们吸入了这些烟雾，仅仅是因为活着，而不是做什么出格的事，纯粹是因为活着并呆在他们的家里。这真的是太可怕了，除非你亲身体验过，否则你无法理解烟雾对你的影响有多快，这真的很重要。我的意思是，从你这里我感受到的一点是——如果我印象有误，请告诉我——这似乎是可行的。
In a kind of a refreshing way, unlike most problems that I see that think about in a global scale, does it feel that I see that think about in a global scale. Does it feel that way to you? 100%, 100%. There's some really big goals out there. And in energy poverty by 2030 is one of them. And I'm proud to drive an organization that is part of getting towards that goal.
这种感觉挺清爽的，不同于我看到的大多数宏观层面的问题。你也有这种感觉吗？百分之百，百分之百。有一些非常宏大的目标，比如在2030年前消除能源贫困就是其中之一。我很自豪能领导一个为实现这一目标而贡献力量的组织。
And I absolutely historically believe it's very, very possible. Sun and Doble is the CEO of SolarBuddy. They are a charity I felt very compelled to support after I spoke with Simon. $30 it sends a lighter child somewhere in the world that will illuminate their lives in the next 12 years. You can find out more and support them yourself at solarbuddy.org.
而且我历来坚信，这绝对、绝对是完全可能的。西蒙·多布尔是SolarBuddy的首席执行官。在与西蒙交谈后，我感到非常有必要支持他们这个慈善机构。只需30美元，就能给世界上某个地方的孩子送去一盏灯，在未来12年里照亮他们的生活。你可以访问solarbuddy.org了解更多信息并亲自支持他们。
99% of visible impact design coverage is supported by Autodesk. Autodesk enables the design and creation of innovative solutions to the world's most pressing social and environmental challenges. Learn more about these efforts on Autodesk Redshift at autodesk.com slash Redshift, a site that tells stories about the future of making things across architecture, engineering, infrastructure, construction, and manufacturing. 99% of visible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed by Bryson Barnes, music by our director of sound, Sean Riel. Delaney Hall is our senior producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director, the resident team.
99% Invisible的社会影响力设计报道得到了Autodesk的支持。Autodesk致力于推动设计和创新解决方案的创造，以应对世界上最紧迫的社会和环境挑战。您可以在Autodesk Redshift（autodesk.com/Redshift）上了解更多关于这些努力的信息，该网站讲述了建筑、工程、基础设施、施工和制造领域未来创造的故事。本周的99% Invisible由埃mett·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，布赖森·巴恩斯（Bryson Barnes）混音，音乐由我们的音响总监肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstad）是数字总监，常驻团队包括
Is Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Chris Barube, Joe Rosenberg, Katie Mangle, Abby Madon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K, a.l.w. in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered about the North American continent right now, but is centered in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely
克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·李、克里斯·巴鲁贝、乔·罗森伯格、凯蒂·曼格、艾比·马登、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7KALA的节目，在Radio Row制作，虽然目前分散在北美大陆各地，但总部设在美丽、繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下的Radio Topia的创始成员，这是一个由
independent collective of the most innovative listener supported podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find a show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or work. We're on Instagram and read it too. But for pictures of bats and bridges and links to everything we talked about on the show, look no further than 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
世界上最具创新性、听众支持的独立播客组成的激烈独立的集体。请访问radiotopia.fm了解所有这些播客。您可以在Facebook上找到节目并参与有关节目的讨论。您可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars以及@99PI关注我。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。但要寻找蝙蝠和桥梁的图片以及我们在节目中讨论的所有内容的链接，只需访问99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。